but while we're working from home we're
checking out a few stories we think
you'll be talking about including this a
tiger at the Bronx Zoo here in New York
has tested positive for corona virus the
four-year-old Malayan Tiger named Nadia
is believed to be the first case of an
animal infected with the illness in the
United States zoo officials say Nadia
and six other big cats developed a dry
cough but they are expected to recover
they say the Tigers were infected by a
zookeeper who didn't have any symptoms
no other animals at the zoo at the zoo
rather are showing symptoms and this
infection of course raises some new
questions over human to animal
transmission of Kovan in nineteen let me
just say this Tony the USDA says that
animals so far cannot give the virus to
human beings and more importantly the
Bronx Zoo tweeted this yesterday because
a lot of people are asking about the
test this is not the same test that was
performed on Nadia that is performed on
human beings it was a completely
different test Tony that's interesting
but this is a very big deal here because
it's believed that the krona virus began
in animals and with the humans so if
it's going now back to animals that's a
whole new chain of transmission so
something to monitor for sure very good
news that the other big cats there at
the Bronx Zoo other tigers leopards
cheetahs and Puma is all good it's a
wonderful zoo by the way once New York
City opens back up everyone should take
a visit